はじめ）え、めっちゃ景色イイ
色やばい
インスタ映えする！
ひっちゃん）インスタ映え
武C）ふふっ
は）うわっ！　前髪が取れる！
は）え！　沖縄良！
ヤバイ本当にすごい！
た）沖縄良？
ああ、良いということですね
は）まじでやばい
テンションあがりますわ！
結構あり
ほんとに
もうだって写真撮ったときの
色がカラーグレーディングする必要ないんですよ
やばっ
た）インスタ映え？
は）え、本当にキレイ！
ひ）ふははははは！　風強すぎて
た）いい感じっすね
は）やべぇ、はげちらかってんなー
は）はぁっはぁっ、腕きつい
ひ）きつそう
は）OK、あざーす
やべ本当にイイ っすわ沖縄
たまんない
本当に住んでいいすか？
は）うわやべ完全にほら
完全にインスタ映えする
完全にインスタ映え
た）沖縄に住んで
28年になるんですけど　　は）はい
た）今でも沖縄かーってなりますね
ひ）これ温泉なんですよ、ここ
は）温泉！？
ひ）この上
ひ）オーシャンビューの温泉です
は）いぇー
た）オーシャンビュー温泉
は）うわ、いいなークソったれが！
泊まりたいとこなんですけど
企画が
た）企画が？
は）企画で飛行機取っちゃって
え、この白い建物！
マジ、インスタ映え！
た）インスタ映えっすね、これ
は）え、え、え、海青いよ海青いよ
た）ふふっ　　は）海青いよ
た）海は青いっすね、ほんとに
は）は、は、早く降りましょ！
た）ふははははは！
は）うわこれが沖縄かー
やっべたまんねぇな！
景色よ過ぎィ！！
うわぁぁぁ！
ヤバイヤバイヤバイ
オーシャンビュー
ひ）あ、ここ綺麗ここ綺麗
いい天気ですね、しかも
た）いい天気、天気にも恵まれて最高っすね、今日は
は）あっちの方めっちゃキレイ
なんかどんどん行きたくなっちゃう
どんどんいきましょ
ひ）あざーす
は）沖縄～
やばい本当に
た）ワクワクしてきた
は）全てがきれい
全てがきれい！
は）おほーなんかいいぞ
やばいっすよこれ
この景色が最高
は）いやーすごい短かったけど
すごい楽しかったです
た）素晴らしかったですね
もう本当にあんだけ喜んでくれたらね
本当にやったかいがありましたよ本当に
は）いや、こちらこそ　　車内）（笑い）
本当にありがとうございました
た）めっちゃ感動してないじゃないすか
は）次来る時は本当にゆっくりして行こうと思うんで、また
た）是非来てください
は）美味しい飯とか場所教えて下さい
ひ）その時はよろしくお願いします
ひ）お疲れ様です！
は）ありがとうございました！
た）じゃあ気を付けて
は）ありがとうございます！
た）はい　　は）では！
た）お疲れっす！　　は）お疲れっす！
た）お疲れっす！　さいなら！
ひ）カメラ、カメラ返さないと！
た）あっそっか！　　ひ）カメラ！